previously on Peugeot stuck I have to
say goodbye to my progress that I made
and I made a [ __ ]
so why would we want this god I'm just
gonna keep my head bouncing on the
ground you guys want this okay maybe
there's some mechanics that we're not
like understanding about this maybe we
just need to like fine-tune use our
brains about this
or what's our brains yeah just imagine
it imagine how this could help us I
can't see I can't help you oh my god you
get so much boost from like wait there's
like a mechanic with that rubber band
for like getting super speed don't boost
we'll just normal jump and just hang out
yeah okay
I'm so sorry
[Laughter]
my god holy [ __ ] try saying something
about tithing jumps and communiques
alright let's try it let's try to
communicate okay all right on three
we're all gonna jump and then boost jump
make sense alright alright one two three
on three damn you okay chill chill I'm
chill wait get up here and be chill not
jumping wait how are you you going to me
oh god okay chill chill chill you see
what's funny about this is this doesn't
make me mad at all because I know things
aren't going the way I woke a we're up
here okay good good good I'm wondering
if the whole three-person thing is
really what's throwing us off oh no it's
perfect threes great okay so we go three
yeah Bob you counted down whatever you
say what we do all right we'll do three
two one go go on go okay go go I like it
three two one go
[Music]
[Laughter]
you go in the wrong [ __ ] way no way
do you know how these pogos work wait no
okay just [ __ ] IV then let's just jump
jump jump just give just daddy a little
face wave you're so [ __ ] useless the
pulling phase is over time to pull you
know oddly enough I can't believe I'm
saying it but I think it is working
somehow well worse we all sort of know
how to play the game this time though
yes true so oh whoa sorry no you're good
I think I'm a good anchor right here I
just need to stay nice and stable spot
no it's not it's fine
get up here here we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we were coordinated and we were timing
it alright okay are we going Bob this
way up here oh hey man oh hey listen
who's up the highest on don't stop I can
to stop boosting save me daddy Pogo oh
oh thank you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
now I'm mark we can boost you some more
okay like trampolines double jump double
jump each other
right right right how we have to
alternate so when when when someone's
okay and they're like at their peak oh
[Laughter]
all right guys we need to take this
seriously you guys
so seriously it helps for stability not
boosting but I like boosting or at least
not really boosting we're all in this
together
suck me in mark is gonna be here now
part of the anchor weight you can
definitely do this come on oh yeah
please hurry please
I'll try anywhere I told you to hurry
okay watch this wait see boink and I'm
uh oh well I can't get to that wall
just that easy way is just this come up
here yeah there we go see oh okay wait
[ __ ] walk off the it's what happens if
I pause nothing I stop movement what we
need is a point man who's doing all the
boosting I volunteer let me get up there
so I can anchor with [ __ ] Wade
goddamnit
yeah I don't volunteer I'm gonna
volunteer through the boosting okay okay
you two you run point wait do not spin
in a circle that's your only not you can
hold down the jump button just don't
spin I'm not spinning all right cool
yeah
hang on hang I gotta climb back up a
little bit I [ __ ] this up oh my god oh
no wait come the [ __ ] up here we're all
guess what [ __ ] we're all as one we are
the no boost brothers and you are them
no boost your are the boost daddies of
thinking about this our boost Wade you
and me the boost the non boost brothers
we get our boost from Bob's boost cuz it
stretched we get a stretch boost okay
alright yes thank you yes yes okay I
have an I'm an idea if we go right right
we go right in the pit we can use the
crazy
yeah be boost daddy
yeah you be boost daddy I think you're
good at boost daddy daddy so we're gonna
have to do the alternating boost jump
thing delay yeah [ __ ] elastic each
other to hell I guess we I guess
everyone just go for our greatest
strength is that we can use lateral
motion to enhance our boosts absolutely
oh you saved my ass yeah we're good Wade
you'll be the new anchor on the above
one and then we're all gonna come up
meet you I would say get up top and go
to the right if you can yeah just get
over there around the tree a major film
oh yes I am anchor we will never lose
progress from this point yeah yeah do a
Wade swing around Wade yeah Wade here
we'll pull you yeah do we want to go
down there yeah it's fine it's fine
there's no backtrack in this next
section so we are officially
oh it's fine it's fine there's enough
room at dillos don't worry about the
armadillos the armadillos are fine I
don't like them I believe in you
anything all right
I'm sure Petrus and you did not touch it
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're just trying to go up into the
right that's all we got
that's all we gotta go how do we want to
climb this we want to go across the
ideal is across but I think we can cheat
yeah yeah that was my bad I felt bad
about that all my bad I kind of did -
all right then it was Wade's been always
yeah god damn it Wade here I'm gonna
move over to the I move this way so I
can get some yeah I'm an anchor I'm
[ __ ] up hanging [ __ ] goddamn it [ __ ]
you guys keep going up I'll give you
more lateral strength calm down with the
lateral beginning to think that our
plans actually aren't doing anything and
it's just random happenstance that
things work out the way they do we're
essentially psychics right now all right
all right you got you got you go we'll
build up some momentum momentum no or
what we do there we go come to the left
we can hop up on this very real easy see
now
[Music]
I'm almost a well god damn it wait
that's the correct way we're supposed to
do this I think that's a way a higher
probability thing that we're gonna be
able to accomplish yeah yeah yeah and
there's always a chance we could fling
ourselves way up and bypass everything
absolutely I hope some day now I'm the
one I'm trying so hard to be there for
you guys well isn't that the problem
then all right come on boys let's go
left
just left is this way don't laugh
make make elves with your fingers Wade
put it on my forehead oh wait what are
you trying to accomplish say it out loud
with words mark are you are you I was I
was up top I missed it all right
I'll be all right it's fine I'm the
anchor I'm here okay I gotta go around
okay I can't see so we have to go now we
have to go left up and left for Dewey
yes we do am i boost daddy once more I
don't know who's boost daddy anymore
wait do you want to try and be the
leader since you can't anything else
yeah way dude
okay wait we'll just just you know how
to get over there I'm not losing my fur
I forgot I wasn't boosting I'm sorry oh
don't blame the strength of our bond
dear boys
what do you mean you can't move bounce
up the room I just solved the problem
how could you not
yeah I'm not moving you guys do it you
guys carry me all right find that no no
that's the problem wait no this can't be
a situation where we carry you I've got
it all right cool
good good good guys just go why do you
turn it mark I'll do it I'll do it I got
this I got this watch this
wait please no and the best anchor ever
I'm close to be oh my god there I go
wait you're on the wrong side there's a
way to go around the barre they're the
actual you're not supposed to jump off
the [ __ ] vine good wait you want to
know the secret I leveled up thank you
so much
no jump off that right yeah yeah and
then swung it perfect there you go there
you go
kill that build it up you gotta do a
back and forth wait I got touch it again
you guys just go ahead I'll be here mark
you could climb up top and try arguing
yeah that's why I'm I do I'm gonna I'm
gonna go over here and help you I feel
like we're really stuck and I feel like
it's only one person's fault all right
mark oh god you guys are jumping against
each other
okay here we go I'm pulling oh not
pulling here we go
all right hold it when he pulls you
swing swing in a direction when he pulls
really hard and we'll try and whip you
around stopping I'm stopping this game
you did it I'm proud of you the next
segment is is a series of fruit hops no
good so we just need to get up here and
then to the right we're going up and
then right look on it yeah yeah exactly
like that you so smart Bob you so smart
all right don't worry
I just super you got it please it's fine
Oh God
come on mark just swing yourself side to
side side to side mark god be careful
it's okay I'm an anchor I can see why
this was a problem Wade you have so much
sympathy sympathy I still think he's
dumb but uh you know if a genius like me
can't solve it Wade wouldn't have a
chance in the world what is that
supposed to mean
say if big brain like me couldn't enact
big brain time you separate out there
still come on
well how how do I go you you be the
anchor I thought I was just have to
bounce up there I need to stay up there
no you gotta stand up there oh okay or
just bounce hi there's something like
that how do i [ __ ] that up
fraud cuz I'm probably going can ya bit
yeah you're gonna be way too oh man not
too Yoink just for a second I'll keep
going to mark I'm gonna get it
are you worried oh there I go okay wait
is that the secret that might be the
secret ah can't reach it yeah no
don't-don't-don't chortle at me it sucks
well no I know you're going through this
like you start to build something out I
have the solution
alright solve it mr. Shaw what a name
who is trapped below lager mayor mark
pick it up here I'll wait bands to do it
listen you had me up there solving the
problem I can't solve the problem
problem I just had to tell you to
periscope
snapchat to the right almost oh come on
oh come on just forget the word pogo
stick yes Bob and I are just gonna go
forward you guys go I'll catch up
oh wait no one do anything I'm here I'm
here
guys no idle be fine don't worry about I
don't know if I can pull you both up you
don't need to pull anybody up look watch
this is where we can really use our
lateral motions to our advantage you
guys it's fine just just don't go too
far to the right cuz you will yank me
out of here oh [ __ ] what's so hard to
move with you two both going opposite
ways oh god it's like having my penis
jank everywhere Hakan stuck below the
vine we have a counter up oh you I I'm
gonna get my leet skills you ripped into
me you act like I was so bad you better
in between while I wait for you to
shotgun
oh don't that's the most annoying one I
was so mad he's like an expert in this
game now last time was the first time
and now marks like don't you [ __ ] use
that [ __ ] sure it's so annoying though
it is down there please someone make a
problem you're still fair go do anything
someone makes progress that was pretty
good way thank you oh [ __ ] oh god okay
yes yes yes I almost made it out that's
what I did you join me back down so hard
okay I'm gonna not do anything I'm not
doing any I'm not doing anything I'm not
I'm not touching the control no way
you're not doing anything right now
you're [ __ ] pulling me all over the
place well apparently my guys just going
for Pogo and that's just what he does
when it does nothing so you know you
guys make progress then you guys do it
do it can you help mark how can
now move haven't helped at all so far
today and you please try yes I'm still
down here what would happen otherwise
for God's sakes
I don't know mark maybe you could put a
little effort in come with me boys okay
[Applause]
hang on I got this oh now we'll see
who's Big Brain here yeah when I pull
you out of there I was the very edge
that little stem from us all going all
the way back [ __ ] is making so much
progress you're killing me right now I
am would eat the Wade Wade's making
progress that's what's happening you say
like that cuz you show up smart I'm so
proud of you yeah mr. level 48 I'm 49
now that's what you get oh my god
oh my god two people is too much Paul
everything's fine don't you guys close
you feel down there all by your lonesome
karma sucks
was it a mark the one being a dick about
the whole being down there saying
nonsense karma I I'm submitting you was
were usually accomplishable it's so
relaxing down here hey come on boys I'll
be your anchor
Wow on the Barry what the [ __ ] do you
mean well this big Yankee all right guys
this is how this is gonna go real smooth
real smooth like Wade come on man how
Wade you got this oh boy
no he's there yelling Cookie Crisp and
letting go of his controller we're gonna
get through these guys I'm just gonna
keep boosting I think I've found the
solution to all just screw everything
organizational wise let's let it's like
a thousand monkeys typing at a
typewriter weird monkeys and in here the
typewriter yep that's that's it okay
guys don't ruin my momentum please there
we go good job Wade now we're cooking
with gases yeah yeah yeah what kind of
gas this boys boys boys I'm your banana
never mind Oh God is everything lost Oh
everything is lost I think it's okay I
got I got it back well just back up
actually we're getting pretty good at
building this up I don't okay okay okay
there's good oh okay wait oh wait wait
guys guys oh God I was really hard
really hard please help come on oh I'll
stay here wait wait what did you with me
what did you do
you just said he'd be he was up top and
he fell down okay that makes us there we
go I'm up Please Please Please Please
Please Please Please drinker thank you
okay pulley anchored you guys ready you
guys feel weighed you know what it's
gonna stay on your tombstone hold the
beer was just along for the ride god
damn it wait can I count on you to
anchor even holily yeah go ahead yes
hang on come to me come to me God okay
okay okay
mark I'm gonna move left okay okay here
we go it's like we've got this big
200-pound baby
oh that was so close oh so bad from
laughing and screaming [ __ ] move
that's the problem
oh I guess it was me that Oh God aha why
here why here Oh God there we go
oh I cannot predict where my ass is
gonna be so I can't boost properly I'm
so close there we go yes please yes I'm
coming oh oh not like that oh [ __ ] this
is how we're gonna do this wait I know
you have it in you what am I doing here
I'm gonna try to get ahead so I can pull
effectively all right okay this is good
win No
god damn it wait I blame you oh whoa how
is it not your fault didn't agree to be
a then to do the side Yankees both side
yanking Oh mom there we go
where am I nowhere yanking yanking like
a big boy I can't move I can't I'm
flying
nope this is our life how do you enjoy
it
ah very good very good like a fine wine
remember what we were laughing remember
remember in sadness I'm still laughing
how did we get this far you're not
laughing you're making a little snorting
noises well at least that makes me feel
better would you guys still date me or
delight me if that was my life I thought
you alright guys I've got an idea
[Laughter]
I've got an idea
hold my beer this is a problem because I
really need to pee but I'm afraid to
leave you got you want to take pop sub
yeah let's go
where we going up there been making
progress yeah that's all the way to the
very start what no no you all no pulse I
I don't want to do it it's not a bad
balls it could be about bones she's um
he's not ideally where the anchor would
be what do you mean your yurt ideally
where I can't make any progress that's
where you are
I'll move then okay good good luck Bob
now we're gonna pull them we're gonna
pull the most amazing thing happened
actually you you fell down and then
somehow got right back as it turns out I
think anchoring is a weakness we don't
need anchors blueberry all right hang on
I am your anchor lucky oye spark a
marquee that's what they say in China
[Music]
excuse me excuse me are you Parks and
Rec 19 spark a mark that's what thank
you both so much hope right now I know
but we got this holy [ __ ] I'm in orbit
one day I'm gonna touch something when I
do just you watch
okay I'm touching I'm touching all the
wrong things and all the wrong places
which way left actually good oh yeah
daddy to clear that no Wade's up wait
hadna got up just then I might have got
up can you give me a little going yo Inc
thank youing you okay a little oh that's
too many oh my god and heavens oh sweet
merciful Oh No you know I keep on doing
that keep pulling handsome the momentum
we good baby oh no oh no man there goes
no no no we can do this yeah my friends
would never do anything to harm me or my
digital character are you trying to wait
trying to drive wedges yeah yeah Chet I
trust them implicitly yeah and
explicitly mmm not so much and
internally trust you internally yeah did
you trust me inside you well not when
you say it like that
that's a little weird way okay a little
weird yeah glad you guys don't trust I
trust you internally well now I just
feel like we're really just doing
nothing we've made so much good progress
and then look what happened to us well
this area is real tough this is um
really [ __ ] hard with the three with
the triangle of pain yeah
going on here here I have an idea don't
you leave us I'm an acre I'm not God
look I'm a wizard
guys I'm a wizard with this [ __ ] how's
it feel Bob how does it feel feels
pretty [ __ ] amazing
hey Rebecca telly be back man please man
ah there we are oh yeah that's nice
please come back back where oh there I
go I'm back
Bob hey you and me let's tether up here
watch we can we can make this I went
that I would back down all right okay
there we go
good all right now we can make this
happen cuz we're where the magic is guys
wait come back tether me right now no
we're full we're full on tether or full
tethered we're tethered full no no sir
what no no no no no no no no watch this
is I'm gonna pull you to victory watch
I'm all right Bob we'll see you gets to
the top first I mean I'm not very good
at this game on my own so I don't think
it'll be very hard for you to beat me oh
good why are you going right all right
wait you and me you and me buddy I got
you thank you
yeah this is great I feel the timber
that I'm anchor don't know ignore
everything you learned before there's no
anchors it's just us and our skill oh
god damn I think we I think are pricey
what our problem was Bob I see what her
problem was it was blindly charging
forward with no concern for where the
other person was I I realized that now I
feel that was a problem we're in the
beginning how we were all like all right
this is way
coordinate teamwork and then that
somewhere along the line that stopped I
feel like you're mocking me every time
you do they got it
here we go all right Wade you're coming
with me yeah you're come over they are
easy peasy easy as she goes oh [ __ ] me
easy as she oh uh okay I got this you
know how you know why cuz I am oh I
thought I had that you guys really up
there still
oh sorry you're not making a progress
yeah it's coming okay yeah sure yeah
okay all right oh my god oh I was facing
the wrong way
look I'm so close each time god damn it
oh yes yes I mean I mean I'm in baby
Claire lost everything Chet yeah I'm
really not good at Oh
how many how many Bulls of this are
there Oh like well we're 31% right now
is it just to 100% oh hey what's up guys
oh hey Bob tether to be tethered to each
other and we have like one person who's
the main body I'm not close up hey I'll
get to you I'm coming to you Bob oh
Jesus Christ I'm in ok you guys are such
a long string oh wait we're different
because way not a triangle angle this is
so good or bad I don't know okay I'm
gonna go with bad I don't like this very
much
I just like so close we can get so far
away each other
oh great guys
mark could you stop humping the thing
and dude I this is so humpable though oh
oh wait don't wait don't wait wait don't
you wait me wait we can get so much more
boost with this mark being in the middle
is terrifying because he destroys both
of us what are you talking about yanked
hey yo oh hey I'm at the bananas no I'm
not I am there I am here we go
come with me it's okay you won't dangle
for a long watch mark wait wait I'm
proof wait is guilty and Mark is
innocent well there you go what are you
talking about let's keep appearing in my
chat untethered from us hold don't you
dare
please please I mean you you're so nice
such a nice song mark one two City the
beginning I did not those wait cut
weight off god damn it I was so good ah
I was so close close you down here Oh
God calm down it's fine I'm up here hey
it's like every once in a while we go to
end bajillion miles an hour
there I am mark help ow
I'm helping out no help better oh that
was so plauche why is the music playing
for me I went so [ __ ] far line okay
we got this fall that would be oh you
you fall out at the slightest hesitation
oh when you say yank you out I'm sorry
those mean I feel bad like yank me thank
you oh yes thank you oh thank you thank
you and I long I don't know why you're
saying it like that but like they I'm
gonna yank you so hard maybe someday you
gotta get yanked on your own sometimes I
just gotta yank yourself I know team
bondage
never thought about it that way I really
want to know what the magic recipe is
for a super yang because it happens like
it's like a critical strike a critical
yang so that thing projared does it yeah
I can do one like back and forth jump
but I can't get a third which is like
what I need to happen yeah it's hard to
get that extra yank in the no no no no
no you know why why wait oh god work
together I don't like that I'm like
leashed to both of you I know this is
old the beer oh god how do we all fall
at the same time gravity you know it's
like why go down Wow oh you guys are
gonna gank me that's what you guys are
good do I really need to stop touching
my toy so we're allowed to yank you you
just we'll help you Hank me I know I
don't I yanked you already whatever
don't whatever me it's pumping I don't
care if it's fine or not it's I know I'm
dull mark alright fine
he said oh my god I wish we're really
going on the yang we're gonna train some
kind of fancy circle yank Oh God Oh way
to stay up there
[Laughter]
just cuz I laughed at that doesn't mean
that that's a based on what you are
definitely not up swear that you guys
were both pulling you freight down I
don't know if that's the wrong idea I
think it is because if I'm trying to
like make angles suddenly I don't go as
far as I want and I go down a lot faster
you know I figured the three-person
train ain't as good as it could be
thanks to the boosts you're welcome here
for you but I lost it cuz no I don't
like I don't like
we know you're the one who and somehow
ended up in the middle I feel like
that's not a good place to be no it's
really not
hey Bob triangle me no I don't triangle
I'm just learning how to deal with this
you guys aren't there we go no no you
know what actually it's probably for the
best cuz this is how we succeeded before
so this is our alright now everyone's it
no you didn't here we go cuz this is
what I'm giving to you my gift to the
world the power of my age okay yeah we
got this nice boom what a nice one that
was a nice month we got this we got this
I got this
you got this I got this everyone but
Wade has this Wade what are you trying
to do I'm giving you guys momentum when
you say it like that I'm here why am I
here I went around the thing that's a
very existential question alright I give
you guys some oh wait oh hey would you
[ __ ] stop doing that I ain't so much
what you're doing is you're destroying
momentum actually no no it's like a
slingshot effect
I'm gonna play some [ __ ] monopoly
guys this might be a 13-4 alert what
happened to me it's mommy did you kiss
your cousin I feel like we're onto some
guys if we just keep trying
it's definitely getting better
and not at all the same thing over and
over and over I feel like the problem is
we're trying too hard we just got to let
chaos be our guide yeah I think I think
that is the problem we've been holding
Wade back this entire time when in
reality we can go bananas Wade every
instinct you have just follow it as fast
and as hard as you could possibly think
of it you've got it literally as the
ideas happen shift them move them around
do whatever you got make it happen
oh my god oh okay okay
Wade's instincts aren't goody goody
gumdrops what I'm doing the next thing
here we go Oh doing the next thing oh
you're not doing the next thing as I
thought oh god don't do this to me guys
yeah me too Wade were you pulling to the
left real hard no I was trying to go to
the somewhere what he doesn't know which
way left is don't I do it's the one with
makes the L uh-huh okay
[Music]
that's how Molly knows it's mating time
you guys don't have a mating roar what I
feel like you guys aren't trusting my
instincts all of my twitch crashed on
both of my computer's so I can't even
see chat right now I don't even know if
I'm still streaming I just need I just
like I don't like it because it only
started as soon as way started making
those noises
brought back what the [ __ ] do I want to
know what that is that's me using voice
modulator
but screaming is high-pitched as I can
okay that doesn't make me feel better
about it
well now you at least know the magic
behind the curtain I'm like Walt Disney
without the money in the mustache you
know what the [ __ ] he's dead outside I'm
dead inside
we're like yin and yang I think he's
dead inside too no no I'm never met the
guy alright I think I'm good I think I'm
good you good I think yeah I think I
think I'm good you could probably beat
this yeah we could do the entire thing
look Jedi Jake did the entire thing in 3
minutes 35 seconds we could do that wait
you guys you're not tethered to me oh no
eyes it a bug just keep looking it must
be just a bug or something we're all
tied together wait and we're gonna do
this I don't believe you
why not you got to believe in us wait
okay I got a I got a I got a quick but
you're not seeing my amazing skills
nevermind I [ __ ] it up
[Music]